ils viennent du liban de la turquie de
l'allemagne ou du québec les kebabs en
plusieurs personnalités et ils peuvent
être tous aussi succulents les uns que
les autres
[Musique]
donaire chawarma giresse ou kebabs
différents ou identiques les longs chose
mais c'est toujours la même chose les
donneurs ce à dire l avion qui tourne
sur le broche en arabe c'est chiche
daouk cecobois en grec c'est giro c'est
tout la même chose
[Musique]
bonjour je vais vous prendre s'y
tenir c'est la franchise la plus
importante de kebabs au québec c'est le
plus grand
ces viandes rôties sont devenus la base
du menu de l'entreprise de nicole drake
amir créé en 1983 compte maintenant 80
succursales au québec c'est pas commun
aux quelque chose qui te paraît déjà
tout peut manger c'est un fast food qui
est bon pour la santé et je trouve les
québécois et même de
savoir et c'est pour ça que
la méthode de cuisson du kebab s'est
développé à l'époque byzantine par
nécessité parmi les tribus nomades les
soldats utilisaient leur épée pour
griller de la viande sur feux à ciel
ouvert
le kebab était autrefois rôti
horizontalement la posture verticale ne
fut définitivement adoptée qu'en 1867 le
kebab ou d'honneur et populariser et à
istanbul en 1945 et commence à être
commercialisés sous forme de sandwich
dans les années 60 en parallèle il est
importé à athènes et on l'appelle giros
en iran il devient koubbi d ici dans les
maritimes on l'appelle de nerfs et au
liban on commande des chiche taouk ou
des chawarma le plus important c'est la
qualité qu'on a
j'utilise seulement le patron de public
and et bien on utilise des viandes tu
étais là ici on a la production de la
journée
mon ami siphonner les dossards en
poulets et des poitrines de poulet des
poitrines de plus 100 dos c'est tout
refroidi à l'ail on a de la poitrine de
poulet mariné on note du boeuf mariné et
de l'agneau marine et
un cinquième essai de l'ast hachage le
plus épais du un chèque de 10 kg on en
sache au moins entre 5 et 6 mai kg par
jour se passe et s'en vont à mon goût de
produits finis pouvant il par la science
à votre chevet dans nos restaurants
il ya un par sens qu'il monte ça selon m
et sur leurs proches le viande de boeuf
et à nyon pour les charmes appris la
riche histoire si les poules et les
poitrines de poulet
la viande commence à cuire lentement sur
les broches vers 9 heures le matin de
manière à être prête à servir le midi il
ya des traces qu'elle va passer presque
10 poche par jour
[Musique]
mais j'ai besoin d'un petit cours de
géographie on est à montréal au
restaurant citation berlin puis on nous
sert de la nourriture d'origine turque
moi je suis iranien nés en allemagne
cela nourriture d'origine turque avec
d'une crèche de berlin
le propriétaire du restaurant station
berlin mais si sa neige eh bien nous
fait que millions de kebabs sont mangés
chaque jour en allemagne est ce qu'on
parle du kebab traditionnelle turque on
parle de kebab traditionnels jeux avec
les tâches allemands contre forme à dire
à paris en france se cherche les kebabs
tu vas avoir du québec crecq turc est
berlinoise c'est quoi les différences
ces différences et demandent une
révision des sauces et le style de pain
ça c'est fait pis des ces styles turcs
acquis et maisons en effet chaque jour
dans notre deuxième sûr que ça la pointe
saint charles qui la dernière version
allemande c'est qu'elle vient c'est
celle de la new nous en offre le poulet
et les oignons et ça s'appelle donnèrent
dans l'est du capsat serment s'écrie la
même façon la même façon parce que c'est
les séries turques il emmenait sa en
allemagne puis depuis ce temps là ils
ont gardé le nom
c'est en 1976 qui avait mis sur cardy
norman c'est le prix mais monsieur
turquie dans une station en berlin en
kreizberg qui a fait le premier sandwich
döner kebab depuis cet angle là c'est
devenu une le plus gros fast food en
allemagne partout en europe tu vas
trouver dans en france en belgique et en
allemagne dont les l'est europe dans le
sud partout la semaine même en amérique
des noirs à new york los angeles va
trouver maintenant partout des kebabs
citation berlais à son sandwich spéciale
et pour cause le creux du berbère donc
ça c'est vraiment votre signature
avec les légumes sautés la fromage feta
ben moi je vais goûter à votre spéciale
en fait je vais essayer de rester
élégant en fait parce que ça c'est la
grosse grue vraiment c'est vraiment
délicieux lycée c'est différent c'est
différent c'est pas la même chose quand
même si goûteux je pense avec vous se
défend d'expérience
ici on a ajouté une touche québécoise au
kebab donnèrent chiche kebab giros ou
chawarma la touche malaise chez nous
c'est vraiment la poutine de l'air c'est
une poutine avec la viande donnèrent le
monde y vient ici ils capotent sûr ça
alors method man et complété
[Musique]